welcome everybody we're down to just the
last two shows of the year and it in one
sense the news has been kind of slow the
last few days but in another sense we
have entered what is maybe the craziest
time since the start of the pandemic in
terms of the coming together of number
one extreme pandemic fatigue number two
an outrageously contagious variant with
record number of cases which officially
are not even close to what the real
number of infections is and we will talk
to that and it is abundantly clear that
the next
I would say six to eight weeks are going
to be
extremely extremely unstable in terms of
the range of the sorts of reports that
we're going to get so I mean let's just
go through it as predicted the extremely
contagious Omicron variant is Rip
roaring its way through the United
States record numbers of cases over the
last couple of days as the data from the
holiday weekend has been processed we
had on yesterday 313
000 cases officially reported now it's a
crucial uh detail to understand
this is nowhere close to the real number
if you do an at-home test and they're
positive and then you don't go and get a
PCR at some location that officially
reports these numbers that positive home
case doesn't show up in these numbers in
addition because somewhere between 40
and 60 percent of Omicron infections are
completely asymptomatic or almost
completely asymptomatic you might have a
slight headache little scratchy throat
not even something that would say to you
I've got to go get tested a ton of
people aren't even getting tested never
mind only getting a home test so you
know Dr fauci talked about we might see
a million cases A Day in the United
States
we may be there already when you have
three hundred and twelve thousand
officially reported cases you can
conservatively assume that between home
positive tests and people who don't even
get tested you've got at least two times
that number which would put us at about
650 maybe even three times that number
so these are completely incredible
numbers other signs that this is
absolutely everywhere include positivity
rates in some places New York City
now has a positivity rate of almost 20
percent meaning if you go and just look
at the percentage of tests that are
coming back positive it's about one out
of five almost one in five New Yorkers
who took covid tests received positive
results in the latest batch of data
um the latest case count is a drop
but overall testing surged ahead of the
holidays skewing the figures in England
there's a report that if you have cold
symptoms right if you look at the sub
this is now not a subset of people
getting tested this is the this is a
subset of just people with cold symptoms
half of them are believed to have covid
the Omicron variant which is now
dominant in the UK now on that note
Omicron being dominant this is the next
level of chaos if you've been following
the question
what percentage of American cases are
Omicron versus delta there was a report
from about I want to say 10 days ago
which said something like 75 percent of
U.S cases were then Omicron suggesting
that by now it's got to be close to 100
not so fast that data was mistaken there
is now a new report from the CDC which
cuts the estimate of the prevalence of
Omicron in the United States Omicron is
growing dramatically in the U.S but the
numbers we got were wrong the CDC
revised downward the estimate of the
percentage of covid that is now Omicron
according to agency data Omicron
accounted for 59 of all infections as of
December 25th now remember the week of
the 18th they said Omicron is already 73
turns out that was only 22 percent and
the number is now 59 so is Omicron more
contagious than Delta yes is it
increasingly a larger share of all U.S
cases yes but the numbers were wrong the
numbers that we originally got were
wrong and the new estimates as the hill
rights mean that while a majority of new
infections are Omicron
Delta has not been sidelined and is
still about 41 of infections so that is
again another uh uh change which is we
thought that by now it would be all
Omicron it turns out that it is not as
of a few days ago it was about 60
meaning 40 percent of cases are still
Delta Delta and Omicron presenting with
different uh severity different symptoms
different level of vaccine evasion
another element of chaos is the CDC
deciding to change the quarantine and
the isolation guidelines and what I
initially suspected was a change mostly
motivated by economics and finance and
and meaning we just industry wants
people working
seems to be exactly that and so much
confusion over these new guidelines the
CDC has shortened recommended isolation
and quarantine periods for the general
population
the CDC is sort of saying it's medically
oriented although many doctors are
saying it's not really clear that
there's a medical justification here
there's a debate about that right now
the new rules are
CDC is shortening the recommended time
for isolation from 10 days
to five days if you have coveted if you
were asymptomatic followed by five days
of wearing a mask around others
the change is motivated by science
demonstrating that the majority of
transmission is happening early in the
one to two to two days prior to symptoms
and two to three days after of course if
you don't have symptoms it's hard to say
which are the one to two days before and
two to three days after so this is this
is the confusion uh the guideline now is
if you test positive isolate five days
if you're still asymptomatic leave
isolation keep masking for five days
additionally the CDC has updated the
quarantine period for those exposed
not infected if you're unvaccinated or
more than six months out from your
second dose and not boosted quarantine
five days and then wear a mask for five
days if it's not feasible to quarantine
wear a mask for 10 days if you've had
your booster you don't need to
quarantine after the exposure but still
wear a mask for 10 days and for all
exposed get a test at day five if
symptoms start quarantine immediately
until you get a negative test or um can
confirm that your symptoms are not due
to covid the immediate question is is
this is this just a business thing and
Dr Rachelle wolenski appeared yesterday
on CNN
uh first of all was asked why are we not
demanding a negative test uh listen to
what she had to say the UK has also
shortened its period of isolation to
seven days but with a negative test on
day six and day seven a negative rapid
test why didn't the CDC recommend taking
a rapid test after those five days
yeah really important question so we do
just to be clear recommend having a
rapid test during your period of
quarantine after you've been exposed but
we opted not for isolation that rapid
test for isolation exactly we opted not
to have the rapid test for isolation
because
um we actually don't know how our rapid
tests perform and how well they predict
whether you're transmissible during the
end of disease the FDA has not
authorized them for that use we don't
know how they perform so this is a
really important Point these rapid tests
that many of us have have relied on they
really are more accurate when one is
symptomatic and I'm going to talk today
about my my uh I faced off against
Omicron and I'm going to tell you about
it and Rapid tests are a big part of
what I'm going to talk about so Dr
Rochelle walensky saying you know if if
you're asymptomatic in these cases it's
it's not really clear how much the rapid
tests actually tell us and then the
question comes about are these new
recommendations medically oriented or
business oriented so from what you're
saying it sounds like this decision
well so I it really had a lot to do with
what um we thought people would be able
to tolerate we have seen relatively low
rates of isolation for all of this
pandemic some science has demonstrated
less than a third of people are
isolating when they need to and so we
really want to make sure that we had
guidance in this moment where we were
going to have a lot of disease that
could be adhered to that people were
willing to adhere to and that spoke
specifically to when people were
maximally infectious yeah so there is no
doubt that a big piece of this is just
what are people willing to tolerate
quite frankly and so
I am not blaming anyone for any
particular wrongdoing I'm pointing out
that the case numbers are so out of
control it is not clear we can vaccinate
our way out of infection we can
hopefully vaccinate our way out of
serious illness and death although
although when I tell you my story later
you might change your mind about that as
well we'll get to that let's next talk
about the domestic travel vaccine
requirement starting two days ago there
was this question
what about a domestic travel vaccine
requirement to get on a plane simply to
get on a plane in the U.S from one Coast
to another not internationally what
about requiring vaccines uh major
controversial aspect that is being
considered Dr fauci saying it would be
reasonable but I'm not saying one way or
the other whether I'm recommending it
the latest news is that Joe Biden now
says if his medical team advises it he
will issue the domestic travel vaccine
requirement and the anti-vaxx people are
going absolutely nuts President Joe
Biden said yesterday he would impose a
mandate that Americans must be
vaccinated against kovid to travel
domestically if his medical team
recommends it when asked when he would
make a decision on that
he said when I get a recommendation from
the medical team
the idea of mandating coveted vaccines
for domestic travel has been bouncing
around for months the emergence of the
Omicron variant caused the White House
to revisit this question Biden said last
month he would wait for the scientific
Community to give him a recommendation
fauci uh said Monday anything that could
get people more vaccinated would be
welcome uh and said that it would be
reasonable but that he doesn't
necessarily expect that he said I doubt
if we're going to see something like
that in the reasonably foreseeable
future gen sake last month said it's not
being taken off the table but it will
depend on the medical and health experts
so there's two interpretations of this
medical and health expert thing on the
one hand it's very refreshing after the
prior four years to hear a president say
I'm going to listen to the medical team
it's not about what I want that's great
at the same time Joe Biden has sometimes
used this I will wait for
recommendations to really just do
nothing and and we've seen that used in
a couple of different instances outside
of covid I think it's really important
just to be honest about what such a
mandate would achieve and what it would
not achieve this if if you do a vaccine
travel mandate uh the biggest
accomplishment that it would push is
getting more people vaccinated we have
seen that when people are pulled about
would this or that convince you to get a
vaccine this is polling people who have
not yet been vaccinated and at this
point the vaccines have been available
so long that there's real questions
about
what what if anything would get those
people motivated the hundred dollar
bonus was not a big motivating factor
but when people were asked if you were
required to have a vaccine to fly would
that make you go and get vaccinated and
that was the uh the the one stipulation
that got the highest number of people to
say I would and it was something like 40
in a poll a couple of months ago so
such a requirement would get a lot more
people vaccinated I believe at the same
time right now as Omicron becomes a
larger and larger share of the
infections the effect on keeping
infections down is going to be modest it
will be greater than zero there's no
doubt about it it's believed that in
fact actually that if you have three
doses you are up to 75 percent
protected against symptomatic covid but
there is a real question as to
um uh what it will do overall for spread
versus keeping people out of the
hospital and alive and it will do a lot
as far as that is concerned it would be
crushing politically I believe to Joe
Biden in the media to do a vaccine
travel requirement domestically but if
you look at the polling of what people
think just generally in the general
population
it's not an unpopular provision I think
this is one of those things where if
there were to be a domestic vaccine
travel requirement right-wing media
would go crazy and there would be some
very loud voices saying it's absolutely
terrible but the country seems sort of
50 50 on a such a requirement and half
the country already hates Joe Biden I
think it's basically the same half I
think a lot of the people that already
hate him are the people against the
vaccine travel requirements so uh it is
not something I actually expect to see
anytime soon but Joe Biden says he would
certainly be willing let me know if you
think it's something we will see I I do
not believe we will see that anytime
soon
um remember that on January 1st we will
be doing our 2022 midterm kickoff
membership special this is going to be a
harebrained discount if you've been
thinking about getting a membership and
all the great perks that come with it
including the daily bonus show just get
on my newsletter at davidpackman.com
you'll get an email on January 1st
you'll be able to sign up at that great
discount and hoping to kick off 2022 in
a big fashion uh very very big from the
standpoint of memberships
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that the David Pacman show is
primarily funded by viewers and
listeners like you we have a membership
program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and the benefits are
extensive we do an extra show every
single day called the bonus show for our
members every day there's an extra 15 to
20 minutes of programming in audio or
video format just for you you also get
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and when we do these
recently they've been monthly viewer
Town Halls we did one last night in fact
our website members get a priority
access to participate in the town hall
somewhere between a six and eight time
higher pop possibility probability of
getting on with me during the town hall
so sign up at joinpakman.com you can use
the coupon code better 21 21 almost
being over almost 22 now uh coupon code
better 21 to get a roughly uh I think
it's like a 40 discount it's uh it's
pretty solid you know we talked about
during the Trump Administration one of
the big accomplishments that took place
was Donald Trump getting a whole bunch
of different judges confirmed three
Supreme Court Justices aside getting so
many different judges confirmed who will
shape the Judiciary in a right-wing
Direction Trump getting ideologues and
completely unqualified people confirmed
to different judge ships and it's
important to keep track of whether Joe
Biden is able to accomplish anything
similar and to some degree he has been
now I'm going to give you the story
first and then I'm going to give you the
two perspectives on this because there
there are people who are saying this is
great and there are people who are
saying this is really nothing the
headline is Joe Biden is finishing the
year with the most confirmed judicial
picks dating all the way back to Ronald
Reagan outdoing Donald Trump certainly
um Reuters rights President Joe Biden is
wrapping up the year with more judges
confirmed to the federal bench than any
first-year president since Ronald Reagan
and experts say a growing list of
judicial vacancies could allow him to do
even better in 2022. the Senate
confirmed 40 or 40 as Joe Biden likes to
say of Biden's judicial nominees
including 11 appellate picks despite
early concerns among progressives that
he would lack opportunities to fill
seats on Nations 13 Circuit Courts Biden
inherited just two appellate vacancies
Trump had 17 and that helped Trump make
a near-record
234 Federal coin Federal Court
appointments over four years we're just
talking about the first year here as
Democratic appointed judges elected to
go into semi-retirement Biden gained the
opportunity to appoint many the White
House says 78 percent were women 50 53
percent people of color more are
expected there's going to be votes on
January 3rd and there's going to be a
whole bunch more
Biden nominated 73 district and circuit
court judges overall his 40 surpassed
Trump's 18 in his first year so there's
two different interpretations to this
and you might be thinking how could this
be bad okay so on the one hand the the
one side of this that is this is bad is
that
um this was mostly moderates being
replaced by moderates so the effect is
that even though Joe Biden is replacing
people and getting people confirmed
Trump was putting people in that were
primarily ideologically kooky for the
right wing so while Joe Biden has a high
number for the first year he's replacing
moderates with moderates these are not
ideological nut cases that in any way
they're not ideological ideological not
not cases on the right they are also not
progressives who are going to push the
Judiciary or pull the Judiciary back to
the left in any way right this is this
is the The Devil's Advocate Trump was
able to actually change the Judiciary
and Pull It significantly to the right
and where Joe Biden is racking up
confirmations they don't really do
anything to undo that because it's
replacing moderates with modern
moderates okay that that's the kind of
pessimistic Devil's Advocate perspective
the other uh interpretation would be
um we don't want to go low the way they
go low we don't want Joe Biden electing
equally or or nominating and having
confirmed equally incompetent left-wing
ideologues we want Joe Biden putting in
competent people and everybody that Joe
Biden has selected has had no competency
issue whereas Donald Trump was selecting
nuts in many of these cases completely
unqualified people
um you know it both can be true is the
truth and and we've said before when the
system is what it is you have to work
within the system and get what you can
out of it this is why until we change
the way redistricting is done for
example both Democrats and Republicans
will gerrymander to their advantage as
much as they can when if and when given
the opportunity and we need to change
the system okay that that's one example
uh this is a different situation in my
mind and I don't want Joe Biden
selecting the equivalent on the left of
the right wing nutty ideologues that
Donald Trump regularly selected so I do
see this as a good thing and the
question is going to be can Joe Biden
continue this remember that Donald
Trump's number was 243 judges in four
years and he got three Supreme Court
Justices one of which should have been
Barack Obama's selection of Merrick
Garland which we've talked about Ad
nauseam and I'm not going to sort of
refresh for you at this point in time
but let's try to keep it going and let's
see what the tally is in another year uh
but it's it is an accomplishment there's
no question that it is an accomplishment
and it is also true that it is mostly
the replacement of competent moderates
with other competent moderates you tell
me uh how major of an accomplishment you
believe it to be
Rand Paul the Republican senator from
Kentucky
is being absolutely ridiculed for saying
look here's how Democrats are stealing
elections and when you go and you read
you see oh Democrats are stealing
elections by convincing voters to vote
for them and encouraging voters to go
out and vote or to vote absentee or to
determine how it is that they plan to
vote it's amazing that he even thought
this was a logical thing to put out
there so Rand Paul tweeted out
um two days ago a link to an article in
the American conservative okay the
article we're going to look at it's
called the Wisconsin purchase and a lot
of the article is about Mark Zuckerberg
Facebook and the center for technology
and civil Civic life's involvement in
Wisconsin okay and Rand Paul tweeted out
a quote from the article
adding how to steal an election so Rand
Paul says how to steal an election quote
ceding an area heavy with potential
Democratic votes with as many absentee
ballots as possible
targeting and convincing potential
voters to compete complete them in a
legally valid way and then harvesting
and Counting the results this is called
elections this is called elections look
at what Rand Paul is saying the way that
Democrats have uh used trickery to win
is
figuring out where are there lots of
Democrats who might vote but they might
not going there convincing them to vote
and having them fill out absentee
ballots in a legally valid way in other
words voting running an election and it
really is worth looking at the actual
article
um that that is linked to and there is
stuff if you look at the article in some
total you will find a bunch of stuff
here about the influence of money
electioneering Mark Zuckerberg grants
using uh using entities to Shield uh
one's personal and like there's a whole
bunch of stuff in here that is not the
way I would like to see elections run
but it is legal and it is part of the
sort of status quo campaign Finance
structure that Republicans generally
speaking are absolutely fine with but
then the incredible part is you look at
the strata energy
and it's called running an election so
there's a heading called how the
Wisconsin five sought to implement the
Wisconsin safe voting plan and it says
the Wisconsin safe voting plan lists
four major strategic objectives first
encourage and increase absentee voting
by mail and early in person mainly
through providing assistance in
completing absentee ballots and
submitting them and installing ballot
dropboxes
there's nothing ominous there it's make
sure that people have places to drop off
ballots make sure people know how to
fill out their ballots completely legal
it's called voter engagement
second dramatically expand strategic
voter education and Outreach efforts
particularly to historically
disenfranchise residents
this is their Smoking Gun where where
this it the strategy literally is do
Outreach particularly to groups that
have been been historically
disenfranchised so that they know how to
vote where to vote what their options
are for voting how to get absentee
ballot wow how dark and ominous third
recruit election workers mainly from a
paid young activists who would replace
the usual older election day volunteers
get young people involved typically
these election day volunteers are older
that's a reality get young people
involved completely legal completely
good
um and a distant fourth in emphasis and
level of funding was fund covid-19
safety uh related covid-19 related
safety measures nothing remotely
concerning there just nothing remotely
conservative concerning there
um they also in the article
put in italics as if this is the Smoking
Gun and this is the part that Rand Paul
tweeted out but all of the resources
developed toward ballot curing drop
boxes vote Navigators partisan activists
infiltrating local election office Etc
were aimed at one ultimate end here's
their big Smoking Gun
as Rand Paul tweeted seeding an area
heavy with potential Democratic votes
with as many absentee ballots as
possible targeting and convincing
potential voters to complete them in a
legally valid way
than harvesting and Counting the results
this is what we call voting this is what
we call running an election and uh per
Rand Paul's explanation here is Stacy
Abrams who is also listed in this
article explaining how to quote steal
the election and by that I mean working
to win the hearts and minds of Voters so
that they vote for you here is Stacy
Abrams now you
restricting voting not just in Georgia
but across the country so how are you
going to tackle this and keep up this
fight in 2022
I'm excited to know that when the Senate
comes back into session in January the
U.S Senate is going to take up the
freedom to vote Act and the John Lewis
voting rights advancement act these are
two critical laws that will help protect
voting rights across the country because
it's not about partisanship this is
about patriotism my issue is that who
gets to vote it's that everyone who is
eligible is allowed to vote my job as a
candidate of course is to convince them
to vote for me but my job as an American
is to ensure that every eligible voter
has the right and the ability to cast a
ballot so
um the the important takeaway here is
that for the Republican Party
this hasn't been the strategy for a
decade they are presenting as some kind
of concerning or disturbing strategy
making sure people have the wherewithal
and resources to vote encouraging them
to do so and targeting areas where
there's lots of potential voters for
your side that's called running an
election Republicans haven't done that
for at least a decade they essentially
gave up trying to convince voters on
policy in 2012 with Mitt Romney you
still had it a little bit when Mitt
Romney ran against Barack Obama
they still sort of were running on
policy although the policy was
increasingly vague and amorphous in 2016
it was completely abandoned policy was
completely abandoned Trump still said
things that sounded like policy but it
was not actually policy the 2018 midterm
then Republicans just straight up
abandoned policy in 2020 running on
policy was a distant memory and there's
no indication that in 2022 Republicans
are going to run on policy they're going
to run on trying to make it difficult to
vote and this is what they've been doing
make it difficult to vote particularly
for people that are not likely to vote
for you and run on cultural issues
critical race Theory
Etc you guys know the the roster so we
have actually seen
Democrats try to run on a platform of
policy and voter enfranchisement I'm not
saying it's a platform I love in all
ways I've had no shortage of critiques
and criticisms of the democratic
platform but it's been let's try to get
people to want to vote
and let's use policy rather than
cultural issues to do that and
Republicans running on cultural issues
running on fear if you don't vote for us
brown people are going to invade from
the southern border uh we're gonna take
away what was it Trump said they would
you they would give you toilets that you
have to flush 10 to 15 times and take
away indoor Heating and Cooling and all
these different things uh we'll protect
we'll protect the suburbs right
extremely racially coded language will
protect you from people taking your jobs
and you know raping and all these
different things so now when you
actually just run normal elections it
ends up being presented as this is how
they are trying to steal the election
this is called running an election this
is called politics and just another
completely humiliating public statement
by Senator Rand Paul we'll have it we'll
have that tweet of his and more coverage
of this on our Instagram which you can
find at davidpackman show you can also
follow me me on Instagram david.pakman
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright so
this is sort of like a kind of keep
track segment as we hear more and more
about the people that knew and were
involved in exactly what the plan was
between the November 2020 election and
January 6th the day of the Trump riots
to try to steal the election from the
guy who really won it Joe Biden and hand
it over to Donald Trump in some kind of
a you can use the term coup or
Insurrection or whatever term you want
to use every time we hear from another
one of these Trump insiders we realize
it was much more premeditated than
initially was believed although there's
no question that I mean listen if for
the six months leading up to the
election they're basically telling us
we're going to say the votes were
invalid we're going to say that it was
all fraudulent Etc if they tell you that
for six months you should believe that
that's what they're going to do and
that's exactly what they did but there
is an incredible new article in The
Daily Beast that now outlines Trump
economic adviser Peter Navarro
uh in an interview
straight up telling them what the plan
was and how he coordinated with Stephen
Bannon read the entire article we're
going to take a look at it the article
in The Daily Beast is called Trump
advisor Peter Navarro lays out how he
and Bannon planned to overturn Biden's
electoral win and it's exactly what we
believed and even worse a former Trump
White House official says he and
right-wing provocateur Steve Bannon were
behind the last ditch effort to try to
stop the certification of the 2020
election results and keep Trump in power
they even had a name for the plan called
The Green Bay sweep in his recently
published Memoir Peter Navarro Trump's
trade advisor explains how he stayed in
contact with Bannon as they put the
Green Bay sweep in motion with help from
Members loyal of Congress members of
Congress loyal to the cause
but in an interview last week with The
Daily Beast Navarro shed additional
light on his role and their coordination
with politicians like Paul gozar and
Senator Ted Cruz quote we spent a lot of
time lining up over 100 congressmen
including some Senators it started out
perfectly at 1 pm gozar and Cruz did
exactly what was expected of them it was
a perfect plan it all predicated on
peace and calm on Capitol Hill we didn't
even need protesters because we had over
a hundred congressmen committed to it
that commitment appeared as Congress was
certifying the votes you'll remember
Senator Cruz signed off on gozar's
official objection to Counting Arizona's
electoral ballots remember that there's
this
um this was an issue back in 2000 with
Al Gore and George W bush in that
election as well the way that these
objections work are that a member of the
House rises in objection and then they
are asked do you have the support of a
member of the Senate and typically the
answer is no in this case Cruz was the
Senate guy who was going to sign on to
that staffers for Cruz and goes are did
not respond for requests for comment
there's no public indication whether the
uh January 6 committee wants testimony
or documents from Cruz or gozar but
they've only started to seek evidence
the last minute maneuvering never had
any chance of actually decertifying the
election results on its own a point that
Navarro quickly acknowledges but their
Hope was to run the clock as long as
possible possible
to increase pressure on Mike Pence to
send electoral votes back to six
contested States Now understand that
every time we learn more about the plan
it's the same story that we are hearing
now that we have the memo that was
written by uh Eastman the lawyer Eastman
and presented to the White House about
how this all could work one of the big
three points that was made was make it
so that we put pressure on Pence to
either reject the Electoral ballots from
certain States or even better even more
directly even more aggressively you
could say
seat an alternative slate of electors
what they wanted Pence to do and of
course
legal most legal experts say Pence
couldn't actually do this what they
wanted Pence to do was say you know in
these different states Arizona I don't
remember the full list but it was like
Arizona Georgia Michigan Wisconsin maybe
Nevada uh they wanted Pence to say well
you know what
um we can't trust
these numbers and so instead of allowing
the Democratic electors to vote because
the Democratic candidate won the state I
am going to bring in an alternative
slate of Republican electors who will
cast their votes for Trump instead of uh
Joe Biden that was one idea uh Pence
couldn't really do that the other idea
that they floated was okay you don't
bring an alternative slate of electors
but you say because it's unclear who
really won some of these states we're
just going to take those electors off
the table and what that does is it makes
it so that the threshold for winning
instead of being 270 electoral votes is
some lower number ideally a lower number
which Donald Trump did have that that
was the other idea so when we look at
this article we realize this is part of
that same plan it was all coordinated
the legal opinions that Trump had in
front of him and the idea of putting
pence in a position to take action it's
the same thing that Peter Navarro and
Steve Bannon were working on
uh what else do we have here the Green
Bay sweep was very well thought out it
was designed to get us 24 hours of
televised hearings but we thought that
we could bypass the corporate media by
getting this stuff televised Navarro's
part in the ploy was to provide the raw
materials that came in the form of a
three-part White House report called the
immaculate deception and the Art of the
steel my role was to provide the
receipts for the hundred congressmen or
so who would make their cases who could
rely in part on the body of evidence I'd
collected to lay the legal predicate for
the actions to be taken and the article
points out ultimately states have not
found any evidence of electoral fraud
above the norm which is exceedingly
small I think it was uh
was it was it Wisconsin or Georgia that
found I think four dead people voted and
I think three of them just died after
submitting their votes you know we're
talking about numbers like that uh the
next phase was up to Bannon Navarro
describes in his Memoir Steve bannon's
role was to figure out how to use this
information what he called the receipts
to overturn the election result that's
how Steve came up with the Green Bay
sweep idea
the political and legal beauty of the
strategy was this by law both the House
and Senate must spend up to two hours of
debate per state on each challenge for
the six Battleground states that would
be as much as 24 hours of televised
hearing so that was the idea now
according to this plan
uh you can argue that the violence hurt
the plan
and what I mean by that is part of the
reason why the hearings didn't happen
and you didn't have 24 hours because
remember the day that a hundred thousand
of you at Simon it was actually about
1.3 million different people joined my
coverage of the January 6th Trump riots
my expectation on that day
was that we were going to see objection
after objection after objection
each with two hours of debate and that I
would step away from the coverage and we
would just stream the coverage and it
was going to go into the night 24 hours
maybe even 30 hours we were thinking the
reason it didn't happen is because of
the riots and so one could make the case
that this plan although it wasn't going
to work to steal the election that this
plan was derailed by the fact that the
riots took place now that would lead us
to the question well then why would
Trump incite the riots
Trump has an all-of-the-above approach
Trump doesn't have the sophistication
and the the ability for abstract
thinking to realize well this plan and
the riot inciting could end up
conflicting and causing a problem
Trump's ideas just do do everything do
this and try to convince Pence and then
you know cause chaos and ultimately
because the debate stopped
because of the risk the physical risk of
violence to members of the House and
Senate this ended up not happening now
this ultimately wasn't going to work but
it might have actually gotten them those
24 hours of TV coverage that they wanted
so again it's all out in the open
they're admitting that this was the plan
to steal an election that they did not
actually win I want to follow up on my
coverage from earlier this week about
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones and
um what has taken place over the last
four or five days with Alex Jones is
really remarkable and it it informs a
number of different
um uh aspects of these coalitions that
have been built over the last four years
and their fragility quite frankly
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones was a big
Trump supporter for a long time he's
also a big anti-vax guy spreading
unhinged debunked vaccine propaganda
regularly for the last year year and a
half Donald Trump recently made two very
mild pro-vaccine comments while he said
I still oppose mandates and free we
everybody has to have freedom Donald
Trump did say on stage with Bill
O'Reilly I got the booster
the vaccines are good and the vaccines
work and then Donald Trump said to
Candace Owens during an interview the
people dying overwhelmingly are the
unvaccinated
and the right the anti-vaxx right has
gone crazy some of them now see Trump as
a traitor one of those people is
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones so we're
going to look at a couple of clips and
pay attention to the degree of fragility
for these coalitions that immediately is
made evident
by Trump saying something so mild and
milk toast about vaccines here's the
first clip this one's from the weekend
we already played this one earlier in
the week but just just for context this
is an emergency Christmas Day Warning to
president Trump
you were either completely ignorant
about the so-called vaccine gene therapy
that you helped Ram through with
operation warp speed or you're one of
the most evil men who has ever lived to
push this toxic poison on the public and
to attack your constituents now just to
be I I've been told it's really
important that I that I do this so that
the our content doesn't get blocked the
vaccines are not Gene therapies and they
are not poison
simply try to save their lives and the
lives of others we're about to lay out
the basic incontrovertible facts
that what you told Candace Owens just a
few days ago is nothing but a raft of
dirty lies that is untrue what Donald
Trump said to Candace Owens actually is
true but let's look at some other
examples of this here is Alex Jones
losing his mind on Donald Trump
for what he calls a satanic alien attack
a satanic alien attack
children with deadly poison everywhere
that they know erases their immune
system and Trump is running around in a
stupid red tie playing the part of The
Apprentice CEO it is important to know
that the vaccine does not erase your
immune system telling everybody oh
you're playing into their hands not
taking their shot no Trump you are
playing into their hands and destroying
yourself and signing yourself onto the
New World Order
the vaccines are not part of a new world
order conspiracy idiot Bill O'Reilly
what a pervert does he know how to pick
women up it's just Bill O'Reilly may be
a pervert that that actually may be
accurate it's all just an incredible
joke
I see I I just can't get mad on air
anymore
you know there's a Gregory's report
there's a gregories report they just
followed it's so important
and so let's just air that
and I may just go to rebroadcast I'm not
trying to be dramatic here I just
I may just never come back you know I
mean seriously just let everybody have
what you want let's chip and Pelosi rob
you let them molest your children let
them take your four-year-olds away there
is no evidence that Nancy Pelosi or Adam
Schiff have ever or planned to molest
any children their genitals off you love
it everybody's too busy with their own
life and their own thing and they're on
this and their own candy ass BS to wake
up out of the coma that there is a
satanic off-world alien attack going on
on this planet the vaccines are not a
satanic off-world alien attack okay so
understand how fragile these alliances
are these people have principles that
they abandon as soon as reality
conflicts with the principles these
people form coalitions that are so
fragile that as soon as there is any
difference of opinion you have Alex
Jones seemingly having a psychotic break
look at this next clip I mean look at
what is taking place here because Trump
said hey the vaccines are pretty good at
protecting people from dying persecuted
for supporting trump it makes it 10
times worse because I know podesta's
evil I know Hillary's evil I know
Obama's evil and I know fauci's evil I
know Bill Gates is evil and I know
they're all
but Trump did a lot of good and I
believed in him and so the fact that
he's done this makes it personal it
makes it hurt
Ed for supporting Trump so look at the
look at the triggering
Alex Jones who as he says was a major
Trump supporter cannot handle cannot
handle Trump's mild support for vaccines
let's look at just a couple more of
these all right take credit for it's a
great what we've done is
sign on to it take credit for it take
his sign on believe it I mean hell we're
fighting Bill Gates and fauci and Biden
in the New World War and Saki and and
and and and the Davos group and and
Peter dazick and now we got Trump on
their team so Trump now officially
persona non grata according to Alex
Jones here's just one last thing there's
this uh sort of pseudo this is pro-trump
activist uh Allison Steinberg who was
invited also onto Infowars she also now
has turned on Trump check this out a lot
of you are probably gonna say oh well I
don't care what he does because this is
about medical Freedom as long as we have
the choice he's not even giving you the
choice if you go to his hotel in New
York you have to show proof of papers
now of course remember proof of papers
by the way proof of vaccination
what understand that nobody's forcing
you to go to Trump's hotel you have
total choice there's no obligation to go
to Trump's hotel
that makes sense please Trump do some
great things while in office absolutely
was I a supporter I was a huge one
but there's no denying that what he is
doing is evil so there it is just
incredibly fragile alliances in the
world of trumpism and
um the the the reality that we have to
understand is that these people uh when
you don't really have principles to
begin with and that's one of the
Hallmarks of the trumpist movement which
is
part of why he won is he activated
people who had no idea about the
political world history what how
politics Works their first involvement
in politics was oh I kind of like the
stuff Trump said I'm going to vote for
and so when you don't really bring any
principles in by which you evaluate the
man that you end up idolizing almost
like a deity
um you don't even really
have a political ideology against which
to evaluate their future actions and
that's why you're seeing these very
people immediately turn on Donald Trump
it's fascinating to see and Alex Jones
really really seems to be struggling
there we're going to take a quick break
and be back right after this
follow the David Pacman show on social
media interact with me and other David
Pacman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on Twitter at dpacman
and David Pacman show we're on Instagram
at david.pakman join the Reddit
community at davidpackman.com Reddit and
you can also find the David packman show
on Facebook Discord and Tick Tock it's
almost too easy all right this is a
really serious story
um you know we we talk about
in the abstract how this escalated
coarsened more kind of audacious and
brazen extremist political rhetoric that
has really gone public in a lot of ways
since the start of trumpism has real
world consequences these people are
radicalized for real and then they go
out and they do things in the real world
the January 6 Trump riots were a really
great example of that these are people
who in a great insignificant uh
proportion existed online for a long
time and then they went out on January
6th and then they did horrible things
Monday night there was a mass shooting
that took place in Denver
and it turns out that the perpetrator uh
and we really we have no you know often
in these things we we don't name the
perpetrator but in this case the
perpetrator was a known entity the
perpetrator was an individual with a
known public white supremacist alt-right
misogynistic
uh platform or position we are learning
more and more about this shooter Daily
Beast article called Denver gunman left
online trail of hate tells you a lot of
what you need to know Lyndon MacLeod Who
police say killed five people in Denver
on Monday was an author dedicated to
alt-right philosophies including
masculine Supremacy contrarian covid
beliefs and targeted violence against
the quote weak
McLeod appears to have operated a
plethora of Twitter and Instagram
accounts under the Alias Roman McClay
which he used for his three book series
sanction
in his posts McLeod seemed to frequently
use excerpts from his work to comment on
current events such as a coveted
misinformation meme on Twitter featuring
Facebook creator Mark Zuckerberg and
Microsoft founder Bill Gates
the meme featured the billionaires
discussing their approach to the
pandemic with Gates being thanked for
mandatory vaccinations with Zuckerberg
congratulated for a quote injectable
nanoworm McLeod who was killed by a
Lakewood Police Officer Monday after
shooting her in the abdomen captured the
photo with a quote from one of his
characters in his book series it's not
really a worm so much however I
understand the point
he gleefully indicated some people
required violence to be addressed while
discussing a 2014 YouTube video titled
Mike Tyson destroys reporter on Twitter
McLeod as his character as his Persona
Maclay blasted the passive aggressive
reporter and praised Tyson for using
direct aggression
uh during a press conference Tuesday
police confirmed that McLeod Who records
showed owned his own tattoo parlor
targeted each of his victims
right-wing rapper and social media
personality known as zooby
hosted McClay on his podcast to discuss
sanction in 2019. the host claimed the
book was blowing up Twitter though he
admitted he hadn't read it
police say during a Tuesday press
conference McLeod previously was
investigated but they didn't comment on
why
Kurt Barnes a spokesman for the Denver
Police told The Daily Beast he was not
aware of the connection between McClay
and McLeod but would forward the
information to investigators there's a
whole tweet history of this guy
um including there's a tweet from 2018
where uh Chloe valdari tweeted Maya
Angelou said that if a person is told
they are nothing then they will say oh
you think I'm nothing I will show you
where nothing comes do you think it's
coincidental that at a time when the
left is condemning whiteness Neo-Nazi
activity is going up on the right and
Roman Maclay which is believed to be
this guy's online Persona said finally
someone is saying this maybe Heather
highing will listen to you since she
follows you good job pain demands a
response all of us have limbic systems
and feel terrible when Society hates us
uh Invisible Man by Ellison or sanction
same story different race so an entire
an entire online history of this guy
um another one of these instances where
uh he wrote I start with sexual
dimorphism for a reason biology is our
first clue then you look at thousands of
years of religions from Norse to Jew
Christian and Muslim all demand female
Chastity then you ask modern men how
they perceive unchaste women three
levels of analysis which align so like
typical kind of men's rights activist
misogynistic stuff so what's the
takeaway here what's the lesson the
lesson is that his fiction the fiction
that this guy fell for was the
foundation for his actions and this
stuff has real world impact also
important because and ever I'm going to
do this every time we cover a shooting
now
this was a shooting on Monday okay got a
lot of attention there were 110 other
shootings on Monday in addition to this
one this is constant this is a constant
backdrop check out the specifics on
gunviolencearchive.org but this was one
shooting we talked about and there were
110 other shooting not mass shootings
110 other shootings of different kinds
some subset of that mass shootings uh it
is a constant in the United States
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a sad voicemail
from a guy whose sister uh appears to
have lost it
hey David somehow me and my sister
diverged on beliefs a couple years back
and now she is a hardcore anti-vaxxer
and she's got a habit of saying things
so stupid that they baffle me and I
don't know how to respond and she says
these things with such conviction and
Authority that I don't have an immediate
comeback yeah and in her head that makes
her right she thinks I can't say
anything back because I'm wrong and
she's right when in reality I don't even
know where to begin explaining how dumb
she sounds this is this is the Sam
Harris thing from his podcast a couple
months ago about why he hasn't done a
debate with Brett Weinstein or whoever
else and Sam Harris has explained it is
really easy to start a series of small
fires that are very difficult for even
someone who's prepared to put out and
that as soon as someone goes well hold
on you think vaccines work what about
the Zimbabwean study that showed
everybody got uh worms from the vaccine
and then died of covet anyway and then
you go well I don't know I didn't see is
that study legit I'm not sure I'm not
exactly prepared and then the person
bringing it up feels emboldened as if
they are right that's exactly what Sam
Harris described which is what the
caller is talking about here the latest
example the reason I'm calling you she
sent me a meme
with a child and a father that says Dad
is Santa Claus fake and the dad says of
course not son think of how many people
would have to be in on it
and comparing Santa Claus to covet 19.
yeah
anyone with half a brain can see how
stupid that is I don't even know where
to start trying to explain that to her
you know it it I hate to say this to the
caller but it may not be worth trying to
explain it I mean in the I
the question is what would be your goal
is it just to change her mind or is it
because you believe she's a node of
disinformation if it's the former I may
not even bother because uh that that
that is extremely weaponized uh
disinformation we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the passing of a former Senate leader
Harry Reid at age 82 a very important uh
historic political figure of the 20 late
20th century in in the Senate I would
say Oklahoma Republicans are introducing
a bill to limit how slavery is taught in
schools of course and we will talk about
Dr Oz's campaign already off to a bad
start all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show sign up at join
pacman.com don't miss the second to last
bonus show of 2021.